el cristo resolvió esconderse hoy detrás
de las nubes el día de su 90 cumpleaños
aún así por la mañana temprano hubo
celebración al cubierto y la catedral de
río de janeiro porque el cristo redentor
es un símbolo de todo brasil la idea de
construir una estatua dedicada al cristo
surgió ya en época colonial con la
llegada de los portugueses sin embargo
fue solo en
1921 cuando se hizo el primer boceto era
un cristo que llevaba una cruz
gigantesca en la mano izquierda y un
globo terrestre en la mano derecha los
cariocas de siempre irreverente se lo
llamaban el cristo de la pelota
en referencia al fútbol que ya en
aquella época suscitaba pasiones y hubo
que cambiar el proyecto se escogió un
cristo de brazos abiertos por un lado
para demostrar que en río de janeiro
todo el mundo es bienvenido y por otra
parte para que fuese más visible desde
lejos en 1923 se empiezan a levantar
fondos fue el primer gran crowdfunding
de brasil porque se necesitaron el
equivalente a 6,5 millones de dólares
para él esta estatua que hoy es la
estatua art decó más grande del mundo
incluida entre las siete maravillas del
mundo contemporáneo se demoraron cinco
años para finalizar la se contó con la
participación de un escultor francés
paul landowski que hizo las manos y la
cabeza y hoy el cristo sigue siendo una
de las grandes atracciones de brasil
atrae todos los años a más de un millón
de turistas y el ayuntamiento de la
ciudad maravillosa espera poder
recuperar pronto esas cifras después de
casi dos años de pandemia y ahora que
está avanzando la vacunación